I didn't love to work on location I know
that he relished the travel and I think
on fiddler he traveled far and wide to
find the the population of Anatevka oh
god we more Russians he loved to travel
first of all he loved that he loved
going to different countries and talking
to different actors and he was obsessed
he was obsessed with acting he was
obsessed with every film that we did
together and that's the commitment i
think it's an obsessive pursuit because
i think the attention to detail to the
smallest character the one-line role
because each time there's a bump in the
road if there's somebody misplaced it
makes for a very bumpy ride and i think
it's a casting directors job to to make
sure that the mosaic is complete yeah
and and I told him once I said
believability is everything in films in
other words you have to believe that
that person is playing this role and no
one else in the world could do it better
and I said so its believability you they
make you believe and and so he he always
he always tried desperately to to to
amaze me with with his choices and he
picked some people he has some people
and in this film and he did the night
that went on like Scott Wilson they went
on to hazard big careers and he cast
them and and they all were southern they
all had a southern I think there's no
girl from there to there speech no
compromise in the authenticity and he
didn't want him he didn't he believed
that location of where the film was
taking place you know he was like a
director in that way it's how you get
immersed I think in a story when you
forget about where these people came
from you're just buying them as they
appear on screen and that's really the
goal all right I you know into your next
film
I think was the Thomas Crown Affair and
on that film you gave Lin stole master
the very first main title separate card
screen credit ever given to a casting
directors right that's right was that um
was that a surprise tool in and why did
it happen was it something you just felt
it was time to well I believe that I
believe that outside of writing outside
of the screenplay itself that casting is
probably the most important the most
important aspect of a director's job the
director has to cast the film and it's
not the producer it's not the studio
it's it's the director and he needs
someone to talk to a partner in that
process it's it's it's very lonely and
and and you know you said you said it
absolutely correct the work is done
behind the scenes two people sitting in
an office Lynn and I reading scenes him
acting some part and me acting the other
what I love to see that ed and out of it
would come a sense of antenna I would
say well how about so-and-so and he'd
see a too obvious too obvious it's nice
that's something that that you know Joe
Blow could cast that I mean if they let
me look because I think we can find what
you're lookin there's that word again
open open oh just let's just keep the
door open and see what what strikes